yeah I think it's almost sudden the
death toll will increase I think the the
issue is going to be is finding
um any of the Dead for two reasons uh
one because searching a part of the
Mediterranean Sea that's about 45 miles
Southwest of here at least that's when
the ship sank uh obviously the currents
then play a factor in it but also the
fact that the ship sank in the deepest
part of the Mediterranean which will
mean any recovery of of the boat itself
will be incredibly difficult if they do
try and attempt that and the numbers
that we've been hearing here we've got
no clear numbers how many people are on
board some people have put it as high as
about 750 others think it might be a bit
lower around 500 550 either way if you
look at the fact that 104 have been
rescued and 79 are dead that leaves you
know a few hundred still missing so
whether they'll ever be found I think is
still a very open and personal question
at the moment the survivors are being
brought here um no new survivors I
should say since yesterday so despite
the search rescue operation going on no
new survivors which is obviously not
good news but they've been brought here
to this Warehouse have been looked after
by Aid agencies including the Red Cross
uh the unhcr and local Greek Aid
agencies and Greek authorities some of
them have gone to hospital nearby not
suffering from anything major a bit of
hypothermia a bit of exposure that kind
of thing and then they'll be taken here
to a center where they'll be processed
and their their immigration claims will
be will be assessed from there but the
social rescue operations they said it is
ongoing is covering a very wide area and
this could turn out to be a really
really bad ranking up there in one of
the worst modern disasters in the
Mediterranean and what we didn't know
for quite a long time was whether there
were any women and children on board so
all the survivors are men and there'll
be no confirmation but actually we have
been told by a victim one of the
survivors in hospital that there were
women in children board and sadly they
were being kept below deck and it looks
maybe as though they weren't able to
escape and they went down with the ship
but there are relatives coming here as
well to try and find their loved ones I
spoke to a man Assad Khan who's from
Birmingham from Wolverhampton area sorry
uh who'd come here to try and find some
of his cousins
so are you searching for your relatives
how many rows have you missing there's
three rotors I'm missing we found one
relatively I'm not sure where there's
still more and
um how are they connected to you
um
men women children yeah
okay have you heard anything from the
authorities we've basically we don't
know what the rest of them
so I'm afraid there's not really much
good news to bring from here other than
the fact that the search domestic
operation does continue There are some
storms in the area so that might hamper
things but as well the Greek government
announced a three-day period of national
morning which shows how seriously
they're taking that's unusual they don't
normally do that but this this Crossing
between North Africa particularly Libya
and southern Europe Italy and Greece is
the most dangerous in the world it's
claimed 17 000 lives in the last 10
years and I don't think anybody expects
that this will be the last disaster of
its kind this summer because as the
Waters of karma the weather is better
more and more people are trying to make
that Journey